two positive integers differ by 60. the
sum of their square roots is the square
root of an integer that is not a perfect
square what is the maximum possible sum
of the two integers so the second
sentence is a little confusing let's
take it step by step so two positive
integers differ by 60. so let's say we
have their a and b
so we have a and b they're both greater
than zero they're also both integers so
they're also
they're also both
integers and they differ by 60. so a
minus b is equal to 60 or we could add b
to both sides and we get a is equal to b
plus 60. there's 60 apart fair enough
now this second sentence the sum of
their square roots so the sum of the
square roots square root of a plus
square root of b the sum of the square
roots is the square root of an integer
that is not a perfect square so it's
equal to the square root of some integer
so c is an integer
c is an integer but it's not a perfect
square so square root of c not
is not an integer so that's the second
part what is the maximum possible sum of
the two integers so if we can maximize b
and and find an a that fits it or an a
and b that meet these constraints we'll
get them as big as possible then the sum
of a and b will also be maximized so
let's think about that in a second but
just to simplify this is actually the
really confusing part because c is an
integer and square root of c is not an
integer and to make it a little less
confusing let's just square both sides
of this equation over here so square
root of a squared is so we're just going
to square it so this we're just going to
square both sides let me just
we're just going to square both sides of
this equation
so this is going to be square root of a
times square root of a which is a
plus 2 times the square root of a times
the square root of b which is 2 times
the square root of a b
plus the square root of b squared which
is just going to be b is equal to
is equal to c
now we know that a
is an integer we know that b is an
integer and we know that c is an integer
we know that these are integers so if an
integer plus something plus an integer
equaling another integer this thing in
the middle has to be an integer
this thing in the middle has to be
has to be an integer actually i'll show
you right now that not only does this
thing have to be an integer square root
of a b has to be integer and you might
be saying wait wait wait a second can't
i just set if this just thing just has
to be an integer can't i just say let me
do it over here on the side can't i just
say that 2 times the square root of a b
has to be equal to some integer and you
could divide both sides by 2 and you
could say well maybe the square root of
a b is equal to k over 2
where this is not an integer where this
is not
where this is
not an integer i claim that this thing
does have to be an integer but you say
hey look just straight from the math
this could be an integer but maybe you
divide both sides by 2 and this doesn't
have to be an integer and if this is not
an integer if this is not an integer
that means that k
is odd because otherwise it would be
divisible by 2.
now if we square both sides of this we
would get a b
is equal to k squared over 4. well this
is going to be an odd times an odd it's
going to be an odd squared so this is
still going to be odd which is not
divisible by 4 so this thing on the
right hand side this thing on the right
hand side will still not be an integer
it will not be an integer but remember a
and b are integers so a times b this is
an integer
this is an integer so if a and b are
integers there's no way that the square
root of its product can be something
divided by two where this doesn't reduce
anymore this doesn't simplify or some
odd number divided by 2. so we just get
a contradiction here or another way to
say it is the square root of a b
because because this whole thing has to
be an integer and both a and b are
integers the square root of a b
has to be
has to be an integer
has
to
be
an
integer
but if the square root of a b has to be
an integer then that means that a b has
to be a perfect square so then i'll
start over here so i don't run a space
that means that a b actually let me do
it right under that because it's a
straight result so that means that a
times b
is a perfect square
is a perfect
that means that a times b is a perfect
square so let's see how we can deal with
this a little bit we can actually do a
substitution for a a is equal to b plus
60. so this means that b plus 60
times b is equal to a perfect square so
it could be equal to some number n
n squared where n is an integer
where n
is an integer and let's see if we can
play around with this a little bit put
some constraints on what we're doing so
if you multiply this out you get v
squared plus 60 b
b squared plus 60 b
i'll leave some space over here is equal
to
n squared let's see we can complete the
square over here and maybe we can
subtract this over and we'll have a
difference of squares so we want to
complete the square here you take half
of this so half of 60 half of the
coefficient that's 30 and square it so
this would be
plus 900
minus 900 we haven't changed it we're
adding and subtracting the same thing
but what that does for us is that this
part over here
becomes b plus 30
b plus 30 squared and then we have the
minus 900
is equal to n squared and then we could
subtract n squared from both sides we
could subtract n squared from both sides
and add 900 to both sides
and we get
b plus 30 and you really just have to
play around with this thing and see what
constraints you can get b plus 30
squared minus n squared is equal to
900
and this is just a difference of squares
so this can be factored this is
v plus 30 this is a
plus b or i shouldn't use a and b but
it's the square root of this plus the
square root of this so plus n
times the square root of this minus the
square root of this so b plus 30
b plus 30
minus n so we can factor it just like
that and that's about as good of a
constraint as we can get remember we
want to be able to maximize b if we're
maximizing b a is only is only 60 above
b so we're also going to be maximizing a
and so we'll also be maximizing the sum
so we want b to be as high as possible
as high as possible so b plus 30 plus n
is going to be some factor of 900 and b
plus 30 minus n will be the other factor
of 900 and we can actually do a little
bit more of an insight here we have two
factors their product is an even number
so it's an even product
even
even product and if we were to take the
sum of these two factors if you were to
take b plus 30 plus n and add it to b
plus 30 minus n so we're just taking the
sum of these two factors we get 2b
plus 60 and these cancel out and so this
is also even so if i take two numbers
and their product is even and their sum
is also even that means the two numbers
have to be even so both this guy and
this guy over here have to be even
both of them have to be even and at this
point i think we've kind of used up all
the information in the problem we really
just have to try out factors of 900 that
meet these constraints where both are
even and let's try with the most extreme
things and attempt to maximize in an
attempt to maximize our b so let's think
about the factors of 900. you could do 1
and 900 but remember both factors have
to be even 1 is not even
we can tr we could try 2 and 450 where
this will be the higher factor this will
be the lower factor because we're
subtracting a number here so let's try
that out maybe
b actually let me do it over here
maybe i'll do it actually i'll do it
over here i'll do maybe this is 450 and
this is 2. so we have b plus 30
plus n is equal to 450
and that b
plus 30
minus n is equal to 2 and now we can
solve for b you can add these two
equations you get 2b
plus 60 these cancel out is equal to 452
subtract 60 from both sides 2b is equal
to
392 or b is equal to
196. so let's see how this works out if
b is equal to 196.
so if b is equal to 196 then a is just
60 plus that so a is equal to 200
a is equal to 256 and let's see what it
does to this equation over here square
root of a is 16. so we'd have the square
root of 256
plus the square root of 196 well that's
equal to 16 plus 14 which is equal to
30. so it looks like it might work but
remember
this thing over here the square root of
c
is not a perfect square this value right
over here that's the square root of c
that is not or i should say the square
root of c is not an integer it cannot be
an integer if it was then c which in
this case would be 900 would be a
perfect square but we it they told us in
a problem c is not a perfect square so
this one actually does not work because
this would give us a c that is a perfect
square gives us 900 square root of c is
30. so we have to cross these out too
although it was very tantalizing
solution since it got gave us nice clean
numbers
so let's keep trying factors of nine
hundred so remember you could try three
and three hundred but we know that they
both have to be even so we can just
reject this because 3 is not even
let's so maybe it's 4
and 4 goes into 900
125 times you might be tempted to try
these out but 125 is not even so we
could keep going so then we could go to
five
well once again five is not even so that
won't work we could try
six
six goes into 900 it goes into 90 15
times so it goes into 900
150 times they're both even numbers so
maybe just maybe these will work so
let's try it out again so let me scroll
down a little bit
so you could have
b plus 30
plus n that'll be the larger number is
equal to 150 because we're adding the n
there and then you have b plus 30
minus n would be equal to 6.
you add both equations you get 2b plus
60 is equal to 100 and
is equal to 156
or subtracting 60 from both sides 2b is
equal to let's see if you subtract this
is equal to 96 or b is equal to 48. so
here's our next candidate our next
candidate is
b is equal to 48 then a would be 60 more
than this a would be equal to
108 60 more than that and if i were to
take the square root of 108 plus the
square root of 48 what does that give me
what does that give me
108 is 36 times 3 so this is the square
root of 36 times the square root of 3 or
6 square roots of 3
plus this is 16 times 3 so it's going to
be the square root of well 48 is 16
times 3. so it's the square root of 16
times the square root of 3 so it's 4
square roots of 3. so when you add these
two together you get 10 square roots of
3. so this fits our bill for the square
root of c
so over here we have the square root of
c is equal to 10 roots of 3. it's
definitely not an integer so it makes
that and if you square it if you square
it
if you square it you would get c as
being equal to
100
times 3 which is equal to 300 and it's
an integer so it works so our best shot
our best values for a and b
b is 48 a is 108 if we take the sum 108
plus 48 we get 16
5 and 156
and you can see
when you keep trying obviously we've had
the best result when we had when we had
b being 196 but as we go as we get our
factors closer and closer together the b
is going to go lower and lower lower and
we're obviously going to have a less of
a maximum value for a plus b so this is
as we got from the most extreme factors
of 900 we keep going until something met
this met our constraints if we kept
going if we tried i don't know if we
tried eight and i don't know if that
would even work as the factors but if we
just tried to kept looking at the other
factors we would have gotten we actually
would have got numbers that are closer
to each other and that would have led to
lower values for our b so this right
here is our maximum b the 48 max or the
the b that will maximize our result and
the sum is 156.